andrea trata de factorizar 6x cuadrada
menos 18 x + 12 ella encontró que el
máximo común divisor de estos términos
es 6 e hizo un modelo de área cual es el
ancho del modelo de área de andré a
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
por su cuenta antes de que lo resolvamos
juntos muy bien hay un par de formas en
las que podemos pensar en esto ella
trata de factorizar 6x cuadrada menos 18
x + 12 y se da cuenta de que el máximo
común divisor es 6 así que una forma en
la que podemos pensar en esto es que se
puede reescribir como 6 x algo más y
para ayudarse a conceptualizar lo ella
pensó en el modelo de área en donde si
tenemos un rectángulo como este cuya
altura es 6 y el ancho llamaremos ancho
a esto por ahora este es el ancho si
multiplicamos 6 por el ancho voy a
escribir ancho aquí si multiplicamos 6
por el ancho o la altura por el ancho
vamos a encontrar el área por lo que
imaginen que el área del rectángulo es
la expresión original
x cuadrada menos 18 x más 12 que es
exactamente lo que está dibujado aquí
ahora lo interesante es que el área está
dividida entre sus secciones la sección
rosada es 6x cuadrada la sección azul es
el menos 18 x y esta última sección es
el 12 y por supuesto que esto no está
dibujado a escala porque no tenemos idea
de cuáles son los valores de estas
secciones porque no conocemos el valor
de x esto es un poco abstracto pero
sirve para mostrar que podemos
descomponer el área más grande en tres
áreas más pequeñas lo útil de esto es
que podemos calcular el ancho de cada
una de estas áreas y luego sumarlas
todas para encontrar el ancho total así
que cuál es el ancho de esta sección
rosada 6 x que es igual a 6 x cuadrada
pues 6 x x cuadrada es igual a 6 x
cuadrada por lo que este ancho es x
cuadrada y que hay de esta área azul una
altura de 6 multiplicada por qué ancho
es igual a menos 18 x
bueno si multiplico 6 por menos 3 va a
ser igual a menos 18 y luego lo tengo
que multiplicar por x también para tener
menos 18 x por lo que 6 x menos 3 x es
igual a menos 18 x y por último pero no
menos importante la altura 6
multiplicada por que es igual a 12 pues
6 por 2 es igual a 12 ya encontramos el
ancho de cada una de estas subregiones
como sabemos cuál es el total de este
ancho pues el ancho total es igual a x
cuadrada más menos 3 x más 2 por lo que
el ancho total es igual a x cuadrada
menos 3 x más 2 con esto respondimos la
pregunta podemos sustituir esto aquí
arriba y podemos ver que si
multiplicamos 6 por todo esto y lo
distribuimos en cada término vamos a
tener como resultado 6 x cuadrada menos
18 x más 12